hello my name is mathias from datatec
and in this video I would like to show you
how you can easily
calculate an independent random sample online with delta t
. first of all, click on
datatec de click on statistics calculator
and then it is clear if you
want to use your own data
you first look at the empty table
now you can copy your own
data here
i have prepared an example for this
in this example data
you just want to check whether the
grades in the summer semester
differ from the grades in the
winter semester the scores were
guessed this can  I now
simply click on details in a coupé
and now select the two variables
summer semester and in the semester
because I have an independent
random sample that we have the tab for
independent random sample and now
I get already there are finished results
output
at the beginning I see the  group
statistics the descripti  ven statistics
so what the mean is what the
standard deviation is and i get
a box village for the two groups
then i also get
the levin test of variance equality from the
living history of equality shows
that both are variants and i can
also count on
this  looking at the significance here
below now the result for the
independent test we can see here
that the result is not significant
otherwise the result should be less
than 0.05 so the result is that
there is no difference between the
grades under the results from
summer semester and from the winter semester, thank you very much and see you
next time